hey there boys and girls it's your old
podcast pal Ralph here why don't you
check out the Ralph report that's my
Daily Show Monday through Friday you can
get an ear full of me and we have a
pretty good time plus if you're a
Hollywood Babylon fan and you subscribe
at the three or four star general levels
you can get the entire back catalog of
Hollywood Babylon the past decade of
babylon's for you to listen to at your
leisure plus the four star tier they get
to watch us record the show live once a
week plus there's a live stream events
all kinds of goodies why don't you go
check it out we're over there at patreon
go to patreon.com the route report
that's
p-a-t-r-e-o-n.com slash the Ralph report
or check us out at the ralphreport.com
it's time to babble the [__] on
[Applause]
[Music]
it's Hollywood Babylon
with your hosts Kevin Smith and Ralph
garmon
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
what a lovely room of people I know
thanks for coming out kids
um are they all really here I don't know
if you read this or not but I went crazy
I heard yeah how's your brain
everything's fine
uh everything [__] it's okay to laugh
folks it's all right I got I sent some
tension in the crowd don't laugh it'll
trigger me peace
he's crazy
um that wasn't as bad as just recently
there's no way to start a comedy show
but I lost get it all out yeah let it
all go to the top therapy right up top I
lost my beloved wiener dog of 18 years
shecky pour one out for sheky
um [__] I am more sad than if I lost
my actual [__] wiener to be honest
with you that could [__] go but this
dog was everything you knew this dog I
knew shecky well Dr Josh Roush knew this
dog and some my co-star
that's right you [__] worked with you
had a scene with check I did in yoga
hosers yeah uh but 18 years and the vet
I saw the the vet later on and the I
wasn't here when she passed I was away
and she did literally die in her sleep
I'm telling you this dog never showed
any age aging whatsoever she was Plucky
as [__] just running up and running down
and [__] like that she had the sugar
snap because she was older she's 18. and
then uh she went to uh bed my wife went
to bed she always slept on the bed with
us and stuff and Jen said she got up at
like 4 30 in the morning so something
smelled and check he was just gone all
her fluids were leaking out of her and
stuff like that I know apparently that's
what happens yeah and she's like you
wouldn't have wanted to be here I was
like I would have I would have [__]
lapped up those oh okay all right hold
on a second I got it
you know a pallet cleanser there but
I'll be honest with you man I was like
it was just it was a I was a little it
was I was a little suspicious because I
was like what do you mean she just went
in her [__] oh you think your wife
murdered your dog
I'm not saying she murdered the dog but
she also got like two German Shepherds
she wants to get like a [__] German
Shepherd puppy and then they were like
oh by the way her mother's still here
and they brought the [__] mom out and
so Jen got both of those dogs so shecky
was competing with two other Big Ear
German [__] right
so for a second I was like what a
[__] some foul play happening and so
I saw you know I [__] put that away
but then I saw the vet like last week so
I took those other dogs into the vet and
uh had them check their stool for shecky
yeah I was like [__] you see anything in
there the vet was I was like was there
any I said not for I said come here come
here
anything suspicious about this death
like he was crazy
I was gonna say look it was Jack Klugman
and [__] natural causes I don't buy it
Sam get me on autopsy he said um he goes
Kevin 14 years with a dog as a gift you
had 18 [__] years she's gone like
some people just die of old age I was
like she wasn't a person
[Music]
uh so yes uh the one thing that she left
me with aside from like 18 years of pure
joy uh was the you know the most
important lesson we eat a living should
always remember Memento Mori remember
you must die one day it [__] ends and
it could end without planning you know
what I'm saying like I had my other dogs
they wound down over the course of like
three years you saw it coming yeah oh
God I used to like for all four of them
for Mulder and Scully we love the
X-Files
um for uh Louis for Marty like I became
their back legs for a year before the
front legs went out and then they just
became [__] pissing pooping furniture
and [__] yeah but I kept him alive as
long as I could like as long as they
would wag their tales and want to eat I
was like [__] it man and everyone else
in the family A bunch of [__]
mercenaries man like [__] Jen her
parents they're always like you gotta
let them go I was like [__] you and I
kept them alive and [__] until the dogs
were like kill me kill me
so I had years to get ready you know for
the [__] end but with shecky just
went like that but it's a powerful
reminder that that sometimes that's how
life ends so that'd be based on that
since Ralph is so old I've been looking
in after him yeah
yes exactly
just she's like I don't know [__] like I
woke up at 4 30 in the morning [__] was
leaking out of Ralph
I was like as in life it was earlier in
the evening too
do you not know how sex Works do I have
to have a conversation with all of you
when a man and woman really like each
other
they let a dog die in bed
uh no I don't want you like carrying my
back legs when I'm you know going I'm
doing it I will whip out my magic
walking scarf and walk you around I used
to walk them don't want you behind me at
any time in my life let alone you say
powerless [__] you you say that now but
it's like you were death's door and they
were like it's either death or He Walks
Behind you you'd [__] walk behind me
[__]
that's right [__] you to life that's
what it would be uh raise a glass from
my poor dead Little Big Ear German [__]
ladies and gentlemen we miss you
as they say in the Old Country yes how
are you any animals die no no
Reggie's gonna live forever I know that
so oh my God your dachshund's still
alive oh yeah
that nervous wreck yeah it would he's
gonna he's gonna live forever just to
spite me
I guess I'll live forever Just because
he's suspicious of everybody anytime
I've ever been to Ralph's place you walk
in that dog's like
yeah he looks that way at me and I'm the
one who feeds him what was the story he
was like you got him he was he was flown
to you and he [__] all over yeah this
poor animal my ex bought him from a
breeder in like Missouri or some [__]
and so they're like okay we'll get him
out to you just to just in a couple days
and they uh packed him up in a crate and
put him on a plane and shipped him from
Missouri to LAX in a plane as a puppy
right by himself by himself ripped from
your mother's [__] teeth thrown in a
box not in the first first class section
either by the way and uh when he arrived
he had obviously gone uh all over
himself and he was mortified and
traumatized and I was like no wonder the
[__] animal's a basket case if you
took a baby and put him in a box and
mailed them to Los Angeles they probably
wouldn't turn out to be the best
adjusted kid isn't that how you got here
that is exactly how I got here in
Philadelphia somebody threw you in a box
go be on radio punch some holes and
stamped me up yeah but uh he's he's a
mess so
sometimes Only the Good raise the glass
for Ralph's living dog yeah
slanjo whatever
um I'll tell you right now though
Chucky's gonna miss out on the fact that
[__] we are one month Maybe
away from uh The Flash movie I know and
we all know what a huge flash fan shecky
was
what a poor segue that was totally
thanks very much uh shecky had some
issues with Ezra Miller but she loved
the Flash
um [__] every ever i i surf YouTube
every day looking for like just one
second of new footage of Michael I mean
let's be honest I'm going to see Batman
colon The Flash I think we all are
that's the attraction for most kids
[__] wait man I know some people have
seen it already and then I also saw on
[__] Twitter like a bunch of people
have seen like they gave Stephen King a
[__] screen noted superhero
Enthusiast Stephen King uh [__] the
Russo brothers that makes sense yeah but
what about [__] the guy who made
clerks once you know what I'm saying
like I'm always talking about this I'm
always blowing Batman with two hands and
they can't [__] give me an early
screening it [__] sucks
make a call you know people I bet
they'll I wanna I don't want to beg oh
you want to be asked yes I want to go to
the prom and I want somebody to ask me
I wouldn't know which Warner Brother to
call
Yakko he's the one
he's the one who handles all the inputs
wow Animaniacs fans yeah [__] you'd be
dropping [__] references all night
all right good good talk good talk the
other two didn't get Applause man
they're like no [__] [__]
[Applause]
somebody on Twitter today uh just
tonight this evening when I was sitting
there watching Veep for the zillion
[__] time
um I was uh going through Twitter and
somebody was like [__] Kevin Smith
used to be funny until his [__] got all
woke and so I I wrote back I was like
well to be fair Chasing Amy was 1997 and
dogma's 1999 and they are but to use
your terminology pretty woke yeah and
then uh they've defended that by being
like yeah well [__] after you got
attacked by the crowd you went soft and
then I was like okay the very next movie
I made was Jay and Sal and Bob Strike
Back which had one of the highest [__]
counts of all time and glad went after
the movie and then the person wrote the
this is beneath us on a Saturday night
red I'm out of examples exactly
but you know what he's right it was
beneath us on Saturday night you did
make a movie about a man who
transitioned into a walrus though when
you think about it so you know you were
trans before it was hip
You're Gonna Get Us cancer
you're in trouble because I got nothing
to cancel but you actually had a career
I got nothing to lose
uh before we jump into uh our shout outs
I want to thank our friends at
manscaped.com for being our sponsor
again this evening or woman escaped yes
I'm sorry I don't mean demand
explainscape you
uh manscape.com they are a sponsor
tonight keep in mind boys and girls
Father's day is less than a month away
so if you're looking for a great gift
for Dad if you're looking to shave your
dad's pubes
then landscaped is the way to go what
better gift to give Dad than to take
care of where you came from when you
think about it
you're taking care of the source of
where you first came from yeah but for
him no no don't do it for it whip it out
Dad yeah
you give him the supplies and the
equipment to take care of his gift is
that do it yourself
better than shaving my dad's balls
good point good point and my dad's dead
to be even creepier
exhume that [__] corpse yeah I love
you Dad
get your dad The Ultimate Gift the
performance package 4.0 you get the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer keep dad looking
good for Mom
or his boyfriend I'm not judgy I don't
care whose dad sleeps with uh the weed
whacker 2.0 we both love the weed
whacker this is gonna make me cry
because it's just I'm realizing I'll
never be able to shave my wiener again
yeah
you mean your dog you're talking about
your dog yeah that too
uh the crop preserver ball deodorant
yeah in case dad's balls are smelly you
want to drop a subtle hint
you ever ever had that complaint ever uh
my balls are smelly because you I know
you've got gigantic testing I do have
giant voluminous dangling testes so one
would imagine they've done a plot it's
not it's not good for anyone
for giant balls you say it now but if
you ever had to encounter him you
billing put them away if you've ever sat
on your own balls you'll know there's
nothing joyous about that ownership
uh but no one thankfully I assume I've
only been with kind people who wouldn't
tell me if I did but no one has ever
said hold up Junior why don't you go get
some deodorant on those balls before we
go any further would you appreciate that
kind of honest I would not
keep it to yourself if my balls smell
that's my motto
you crop reviver toner for your balls
too toner I could use some toner I need
some lift
oh so I thought it was about shading it
or something to make it look larger no
I'm not contouring it with makeup
it's the word on you man Chick so like
he Contours his [__] dick
sucking the cheekbones of my penis uh
the boxer briefs also included in this
plus a travel bag the beard hedger Pro
kit also for fathers around the world
you get the beard hedger trimmer beard
shampoo and conditioners beard oil beard
bomb and a signature beard comb and they
realize at a certain point they're like
you know we should probably move north
not just do the balls and stuff the
whole body yeah manscaped has you
covered they even have uh boxers as well
so go check out manscape.com 20 off plus
free shipping if you use the code Babble
at checkout that's 20 off and free
shipping at manscape.com if you use the
phrase Babble go Babble your balls kids
indeed Happy Father's Day
all right how much should we make doing
tonight
uh I'm not the man to ask I just follow
it I just follow orders [__] Nazi
you're worried about getting canceled
you know will our guy will he calls me
up he says oh we gotta buy a manscaped
wants to advertise on the Hollywood
Babylon I'm like great he goes read this
I'm like okay I'm not I don't ask
questions I was I did uh Bert crusher's
podcast uh two two bears one cave
usually Tim and Tom Segura but Tom
wasn't there so it was just me and Bert
right and uh he was talking about ads
and he [__] he was quoting prices for
ads where I'm like they give you how
much
and I was like I gotta ask Ralph how
much we make and [__] fat a lot of
good that dude yeah I'm just
I'm just a worker bee sir I'm not I'm
not the head of the hive fair enough so
you you can pay me not to do the ads if
you want and then uh everyone just felt
backstage for a second though like he's
got no power I have none no he's a cog
I'm a puppet or a Muppet hey speaking of
Muppets man you see my [__] uh Muppet
debut no
[Applause]
Mayhem yes uh a lot of me in it I'm
gonna check it out yeah you know I'm a
big fan it's uh it was fun it's a fun
show
whoa what
let's talk to
this to come particularly long distances
so we're celebrating special occasions
with us here this evening we call this
segment the shout outs
[Music]
get your [__] out
what's up dental work yeah really hit
the back of one of them molars I don't
know if we have a dental plan on this
show either don't ask me that so
uh is uh Jenny here zombie gen where are
you zombie gen
long time uh supporter of the show great
to see you again in the parking lot yeah
she is she has been with us since the
very beginning and she's here tonight
celebrating her birthday so I just
wanted to give her a special shot
she lives in Lake Forest which is down
there in Orange County ish area is that
it's like a 90-minute drive I got two
bucks for you
I put it in a cup come on up and get it
I put it in a card but I didn't bring a
card
is all the money I have on me two
dollars
I thought we'd get money for the
end
don't make out with other people in the
audience
it's her birthday she can do whatever I
suppose so yeah get yourself a very
inexpensive drink
look at that yeah Jen works at the ren
fair oh my God I thought you were just a
gypsy hustling people outside the comedy
club can you say Gypsy anymore is that
canceled no you can't say that
I I thought you were a dirty Romanian
working outside the
about the club I don't know what do we
call them
a traveler a traveler okay dirty
Romanian
hair what I would say is
not one but two for my big brown
luscious eyes shoot up for zombie Jen
man thank you Jen happy birthday
[Applause]
Jen by the way as all she really wants
for her birthday is to be in a Kevin
Smith film someday oh my God that's so
easy can you make that happen for her to
do is be around me when it's happening
some people ask all the time like how do
I get in your movie I was like just be
there when it's happening because I'm a
proximity guy I'm like you get in the
[__] movie yeah
she belly dances
I've never had a ballet dancer in a
movie so [__] it's about time yeah
right yeah done and done all right
that's why I stay so close to Kevin just
in case he makes a movie he'll point at
me and uh I'm like you get this movie
and say say nothing just just I'll give
you 20 seconds of screen time go hold my
dog yes
oh hold on I'll make it funnier hold my
wiener there we go that's better
uh Michael from Brisbane Australia
Michael are you here hey Michael welcome
right up front long time listener
attending the show on May 20th flying
over from Brisbane hoping to make it on
the shout out list well Michael thank
you so much for being here it's not just
for the show though you're here for
another reason I hope right
a couple other reasons what else you
doing while you're here
she's hoping to get two bucks [__]
zombie jet
you guys start carrying singles like
you're at a strip club Make It Rain
welcome welcome uh Jesse Chavez
right up front Jesus Christ
how do you get do you get here early to
get up yeah how do you get front roast
seats
you know a guy Dan Dan Ruiz yeah Dan's
always up front too how do you get up
front
you come here early yeah you got you got
to see somebody about that
Dan is in the front row every show we do
which I love so am I that's true Jesse
writes her name is Jesse I'm a four-star
general in the garmi thank you so much
sir
I'm a member of the Kevin Smith Club
geez what thank you I'll be in tennis
with my love as many Applause for that
I'll be in tennis with my lovely
girlfriend Kathy you must be Kathy you
are lovely I wrote Ben email back last
year and I figured you probably didn't
read it oh I did I just ignored it
um
not everyone
I'm the Velvet Rope of the Rob of the
Hollywood Babylon show
and you probably won't read this one ha
but in case you do I wanted you to thank
Dan Ruiz for being a friend that we see
every time we come to Babylon Kevin
might remember he's from Riverside and
that's where Kevin had his first
experience with central air yeah
the side
born here at the Hollywood Babylon show
grinder let's be honest found you on
Twitter
in honor of Dan can you have Batman
himself Mr Adam West sing they're coming
to take me away with love Jesse shop as
well I I don't usually do Adam West but
if I if I if I have to okay a little
music there Josh
remember when you ran away and I got on
my knees and begged you not to leave
because I go berserk well you left me
anyhow and then the days got worse and
worse and now you see I've gone
completely out of my mind and they're
coming to take me away haha they're
coming to take me away
to the funny farm where Life is
Beautiful all the time and I'll be happy
to see those nice young men in their
clean white coats and they're coming to
take me away
there you go
going out to you guys
I gotta give you [__] major props
uh for your finger work whenever you do
Adam West it's he always had that yeah
that that hand gesture cheer from all
the girls like big props on your finger
words yeah I do
but you always it really sells it I
think like you sound like it but still
when you do this I'm like that is
[__] is that the secret to the
impression I think it is you have to
embody you have to embody
ah
sweating there's more mouth work ah it's
more
it's more teeth yeah that's hot it's
incredibly hot yeah it's unbelievable
you know because all these things you
know he's doing and yeah you know you're
feeling uh you know a pothole and you
don't even know it's not a pothole it's
like people working ha that's hilarious
isn't it I ride bikes
this is there's a uh [__] like a
master class in there should I make some
money on this there's a strike going on
this is the only work I've got only only
directing I'll be able to do
um Jonathan Gonzalez are you uh hey
Jonathan how are you JG been a fan of
the podcast since day one first time
seeing you guys live since the John
Lovitz Comedy Club wow wow look at the
[__] look at that old school shirt that
was one of our first shirts keep calm
and Babylon look at that you're not
proud enough to wear it but you brought
it in your purse uh that's fine whatever
whatever it's a fine I used to really
enjoy man I love doing the show whenever
we do it but I remember that was the
early heydays of the show where first we
started its mod castle with like 48
seater and [__] yeah we moved up to the
love it's and going to City Walk on a
Friday night or a Saturday night was
like to me I was like I've made it
because we're working where you could
buy a [__] Cinnabon that's right
you can leave this show and go bold yeah
thank you
[Applause]
what's uh Al Pacino is there any hand
work there
oh yes
gotta slap something that's that's
Pacino funny you should ask why because
Jonathan says at this point of the night
the Edibles we've ingested have most
likely kicked in
yeah
very funny yeah I'm sure that [__]
dead dog talk really harshed your Buzz
we are high so Kevin doesn't have to be
well how nice for you guys to make that
that's true on Tuesday it'll be 17 weeks
wow Weed Free
don't applaud that I do have a plan I
have 15 years first 15 years of my
career I I didn't smoke weed which is
weird because of all the Jay and Silent
Bob movies second 15 years of my career
I did smoke weed this next 15 not gonna
smoke weed cook Coke yeah [__] doing
rails like crazy but when I turn 67 yeah
back to weed oh really yeah and then
ride it into the grave not gonna jump
the horse or something just like pick a
new drug maybe there'll be something
Space Age and futuristic at that point
that'll be like you know how they have
Edibles now plug your brain into some
coaxial cable or something that sounds
dangerous
uh we're having also multiple cocktails
in your honor Ralph well thank you so
much I recommend that highly uh speaking
of Al Pacino to celebrate seeing you
guys alive again after so long I'd love
to be serenaded by Al Pacino singing
Never Gonna Give You Up
she says this is new this is a first so
don't judge me this is a new experiment
we'll have to we're gonna Rick Roll with
Pacino I'm gonna Rick Roll I'm gonna owl
roll
give me a little music there Josh
[Music]
oh
we're no strangers to love
you know the rules and so do I
a full commitments what I'm dreaming of
you wouldn't get this from any other guy
I want to tell you how I'm feeling
I gotta make you understand Never Gonna
Give You Up Never Gonna Let You Down
never gonna run around dessert you
Never Gonna Make You Cry
never gonna say goodbye never gonna tell
a lie and [__] hurt you
there you go
[Applause]
oh [__] well I've got the camera out
we've got a show in Jersey in two weeks
yeah we do can we do a quick ad yeah you
gotta sit through a quick ad sure
um so say uh New Jersey man we're coming
to the spot Castle to do Babylon really
that's the one
you're right don't say New Jersey say
New York New Jersey okay no say New York
New Jersey and Pennsylvania no that's
too many words say tri-state area how
about East Coast
you know what go for America
and Europe
they can make an easy trip across the
ocean everybody okay
hey East Coast we're bringing Hollywood
a lot of pressure I'm not a first take
guy are you talking my movie I know
all right stay tuned
hey there East Coast we're bringing
Hollywood Babylon to you in New Jersey
I'm sorry hey there what the [__] what
you what this is the Mickey Mouse Club
hey there hi there hold there
say say something [__] say curse and
do it as a famous person there you go
that's what they want dance monkey
ah east coast how are you yes it's gonna
be incredible we're gonna be doing
Hollywood Babylon for you just you in
New Jersey where where at the at the
Smart Castle Cinemas in the Atlantic
Highlands New Jersey well remembered um
what is the uh What uh what's the date
uh the date is June 3rd it's going to be
unbelievable I'll be there and I'll be
digging a hole outside the theater and
then filling it in again because
that's what I do these days
uh a ticket to C spot.com I get your
tickets at csmathi.com or smart Castle
Cinemas or smartcastlecinemas.com and
don't forget Gardens Galaxy 3 still
playing and don't forget Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 is still playing so you
can see uh the baby rabbit
and cut give it up for help everybody
[Music]
foreign
make me stay far away
a nice two-minute commercial yeah
uh Heath Louie Heath Louis are you here
hi Heath how are you
th is also here from Australia Sydney
Australia uh joining me will be my wife
Michelle who will be celebrating her
40th birthday next week happy birthday
Michelle
[Applause]
yeah next week so you're no zombie Jen
it's close enough
she's an absolute Gem of a woman who
I've been lucky enough to spend the last
16 years with I love how she continually
supports me and puts up with all my
nerdy Hobbies like attending this show I
can only imagine
you're dragged to [__] America and
then you're dragged to the show oh my
God so you could do anything we're in
Los Angeles you get a [__] same-sex
encounters like let's go watch a former
radio guy in a [__] former director
talk about his dead dog
that should be the commercial for the
Jersey show that's really
really that really sells it Kev way to
make me feel good early in the show
I was hoping David Bowie could sing
Michelle an early happy birthday well of
course we can Heath that's what we do
here Josh
happy birthday to you Michelle
happy birthday
yep all the way from Sydney now you'll
hear in Los Angeles
celebrating your birthday next week now
you're going to have a birthday
we wish you happy birthday
next week on the actual day happy
birthday to you Michelle
[Music]
happy birthday Michelle
[Applause]
for [__] sake
it's been a minute don't break the shell
[Laughter]
uh who's this from Samantha Hannah
Michelle yeah Samantha Hannah hi
Samantha Hannah hi how are you
uh Samantha writes today is my fiance's
birthday what's your fiance's name
Andrew happy birthday Andrew
congratulations happy birthday we've
been together eight years on June 5th
which is the anniversary of our first
date which incidentally was also at a
Hollywood Babylon show the [__]
seriously
The Improv in Irvine
your show brought us together we bonded
immediately over a mutual love of HBO
and Kevin Smith movies
remember those yes I like those we're
Ralph report listeners from the
beginning and now our day doesn't feel
complete without it thank you so much
guys uh I'm incredibly grateful to you
both for creating a community where I
can meet this amazing man who stood by
me when both of my grandparents passed
and my uncle was diagnosed with cancer
in the first six months of our
relationship Jesus I thought I was
bringing the show down yeah dog material
[__] lady come on it's a comedy show
something funny happened or not
um
that's really nice you guys met because
of the show yeah yeah and he turned out
to be a good man
and most of the people listen to the
show are not good people so
ah come on
how long you guys been together eight
years [__] hey man this man taught me
how to drive when I was too traumatized
from losing my sister in a car accident
to learn how to drive
what the [__] with the life of Job man
how good is she in bed that's all I keep
thinking
why does grief make one good no but he's
like she's she's just a nightmare she's
she's cursed everyone around her dies
but I just can't give it up
[Music]
she's just tragedy on two legs but I
just I can't leave that [__] that's
what he's thinking it's like a [__]
Shakespeare play
he supported me through college and
continues to do everything in his power
to make me smile that's got to be a
chore given here [__] life
Jesus
Queen Doom and Gloom over there
do something to make him smile oh you're
gonna blow him while we watch
come on up yeah [__]
that'll turn that frown upside down turn
it into a circle
laughs
you have a circle of life yeah yeah yeah
sure yeah
I haven't told him I was writing you
guys but I was hoping to surprise him
with Kevin marrying us
we got in jail I hate to break your
heart but I'm already married no no not
that you're not marrying them you're
using your power siding over there oh
[__] my power from the Universal Life
Church fusing humans together as one yes
you're ordained you can actually marry
them in this room tonight
do you want that
we got it okay would that make you happy
we got engaged a couple years ago and I
can think of no better way to move
forward than to have the people who
started our relationship bring it to the
next level
we'll be moving up to the Four Star
level on the Ralph report well we're
doing it now that's for sure
Kevin Smith's podcast for spear
subscriptions or definitely [__]
doing it what is the difference between
the three star and the four star how
much uh you get swag and stuff and
access to me and things and you know
phone sex you know all the usual things
access to me yeah come over to the house
yeah sure
you guys want to watch Quincy come over
my house I don't buy it natural causes
um [__] hey man let's marry these two
kids what are you saying come on up
what are you gonna do while I'm doing it
I'll just hold the mic okay can you
shoot it as well oh for [__] sake what
am I
what am I an octopus I know it's a lot
to ask it is a lot to ask Dan do you
want to shoot it
yeah Dan make yourself useful you're in
the fun [__] row every week
do me a favor don't look at my dick pics
all right
he doesn't mean his dick pics by the way
all right so wait it's Sam and who it
says Samantha and um
Andrew welcome to the stage Samantha and
Andrew everybody
and she made us dolls of of our of each
of us oh my God
look at you
I am holding a beat you're holding a
beat oh thank you so much how adorable
hey man these look like uh voodoo dolls
quite frankly
so they can make out
turn around
oh [__] lovely
chain why do I have
what you think I'm a biker what the hell
yeah no because you hate America great
Kids jump and jump into the come into
the cathedral here face face uh well
face rev face each other that'd be a
problem watch the court you're getting
married at a comedy club this will be
something to tell the kids about the
open up so Dan can see me yeah
I know you're getting married and all
but this is Kevin's shot yeah
uh okay uh kids uh here I'm gonna you
put your one hand down and then you put
one hand on top of hers and then a
[__] Hokey Pokey yes
it's very ceremony and then you put your
hand on top of mine all right I put my
hand here no get the oh
you put your other hand Sam and then
Andrew put your hand there there you go
all right Babylon on three
thank you
[Music]
you're right it's a little [__]
sporty oh just put your whole sports
ball right there yeah okay uh okay uh uh
let's see uh how do we begin oh yes
mileage no that's not you no that was
another guy
um ladies and gentlemen we are gathered
here today ostensibly to do a podcast
but [__] but now something more
important is gonna happen kids you came
here to get some [__] gas and some
Giggles you're gonna watch two human
beings get fused together in holy
matrimony
what what it wants to is gonna become
one this is like a [__] island of Dr
Moreau type situation
they enter the [__] Arena as two and
they'll leave the steel cage is [__]
one and that's what marriage is ladies
and gentlemen a mutation yes
um before we go further before I do
ceremonial [__] uh tell us
how you well you really heard how you
met yeah tell us how you felt tell us
the first time that you told him that
you loved him there you go all right the
first time I told him I loved him it was
after a party
um and he was drunk and I said I love
you and he's he didn't say it back
perhaps you want to marry someone else
yeah
there's other options it's not too late
how long after the first time you said I
love you did he finally say that he
loved it I think it was only like a
month later
what were you holding out for man head
Andrew uh what do you keep in mind
there's a lot of Death Around things at
the time that's true what do you
remember about the first time that you
uh told Samantha you loved her
um I was uh pretty nervous shaking and I
don't know if she was gonna say it back
to me after a month but
I I said in a it felt right it felt
right that time
that time it felt right
it's never going to be more right than
this time because this is the most
[__] important man you guys bring
Rings or no
that's okay give each other the dolls
we're not the dolls but take his chain
off
wallet chain you don't need Rings man
rings are a [__] outward symbol and
what we're looking for here is an inward
symbol yeah
thank you yeah just came up with that
just that was good that was good don't
tell the writer's Guild but I just wrote
that right now
Gab
and scabs is what marriage is All About
Kids
[Laughter]
um I remember getting married I remember
standing across from My Wife and she was
like eight months pregnant and um you
know I was like all right we better do
this and uh
and I remember thinking going into it
well [__] this is just like the
dating plus like we've been dating for a
while this would just be like that but
something strange happened when we stood
across from one another we looked in
each other's eyes look at her [__]
eyes
we were looking at each other's eyes and
and I saw something that I've been
looking for my whole life man the person
that I wondered you know I saw my
parents be marriage ever since I was a
kid and I was like one day I'll have
that I hope one day I hoped I would have
it I didn't know I would have it [__]
but my whole life I was wondering what
would that person that I'd spend the
rest of my life with look like and then
in that moment I realized oh [__] it's
this [__] so uh
so suddenly it went from just something
simple of like you know this will be
dating plus just something real and I'll
never forget uh the priest he was a
Dutch Catholic monk and he said to us
Dutch Catholic he had a lot of pretzels
on them and uh
and he said something he said like uh
you know what we're about to do right
now is so real
that only the the government can
dissolve it like if you want to end this
after this you have to get the state
involved and I remember thinking well
that's [__] dire yeah but that's how
serious it is man to enter and they
leave as one fused together and and the
Universal Life Church has given me this
[__] power for fifteen dollars it's
worth it I think
to fuse two [__] together at
the genitals and the Heart
so uh In This Very holy moment with
Ralph as our witness and look at him
cucking it out right there I I couldn't
be happier can't [__] wait uh I say
to you uh Samantha do you take Andrew to
be your lawfully wedded husband there's
a home sorry get the [__] mic out of
her face yeah the worst [__] altar
boy I'll tell you that right now because
it's all about you Cam it really is
you got me Dan
Samantha do you take Andrew to be your
lawfully wedded husband to have and to
hold in sickness and in health for
richer and for poorer and here's the
most metal part of the vows till death
do you part now the mic in her face I do
yeah
yes
so hot
and when she says Death to Your Part she
means it because she knows
she has had a [__] ton of death that's
all I'm saying
she's for real
Samantha no you already asked her
Andrew Andrew
do you take Samantha I had my hand on
him though
so I was saying do you take him so I got
to put my hand on her now okay do you
take Samantha otherwise I'm doing this
twice yeah you don't want that and
everyone's like why do you keep touching
the guy right and then we can't do the
show in Florida anymore all right all
right fair enough we gotta go
uh Andrew do you take Samantha here to
be your lawfully wedded wife to have and
to hold in sickness and in health for
richer and for poor no matter how many
of her relatives die
and here's the most metal part of the
vows till death do you part
I do
don't applaud yet it's not over no hold
that man uh kids
uh I know
this is look I just want to take a
moment to be serious here because we're
in a comedy club and [__] nobody really
ever wants to get religious in a comedy
club but if you're going to bind people
together man we have to invoke
holy things so [__] if you're one of
those people who don't believe in that
[__] just [__] put that to the side
because for the next few moments we're
going to do something very sacred
repeat after me these sacred vows and
and Brightest Day
brightest Brightest Day in Blackest
Night and Blackest Night no evil shall
Escape my sight no evil shout Escape my
sight those who worship evils might
those who worship evils might beware my
power beware my power Green Lantern's
life
by the power invested me by the
Universal Life Church I Now Pronounce
You man and wife you make is the bride
[Applause]
give it up for Samantha and Andrew
congratulations
thank you guys
congratulations kids
your new moniker shall be samandra oh I
like that
don't worry yeah
well that was [__] that was fun we
shouldn't negotiated to watch their [__]
I know
honeymoon [__] right where you guys
going after the show
parking lot
what the [__] happened to my phone
give it up for Dan he shot the picture
thank you Dan
I so so hope it's just eight minutes of
Dan's face
no look at that shot oh that's nice yeah
well composed all right we can watch the
whole let's relive it no let's not thank
you Dan
[__] we're out of time the show's over
now yeah
I know but it was worth it because we
got dolls
we also get emails from all around the
world Josh
about you
don't drink
garmin's got an email man
featuring Kevin's reactions that's right
this email comes from that's here for Dr
Josh Roush by the way on the line on the
sights and sounds this evening
the third member of this show did I read
online or giving out wrong reasons
t-shirts tonight Josh got two left a
small and a large wow
that was [__] fast I was gonna say
let's make a game of it but [__] now
right people love free [__]
but we got two people just got married
probably should have given them the
shirts yeah
that's their gift to each other I want
my free [__] t-shirt
spoken like a single person
he's got married [__] them
their happiness I want a t-shirt
winners wrong reasons come out sir plug
plug uh August 15th on streaming and
Blu-ray yeah
featuring commentary by Kevin Smith
oh
no one asked me to do any [__]
commentary
just saying they're in the movie I know
that's why I thought maybe somebody you
know because your commentary would be
like who made it
and I got work saying look this ain't no
Kevin Smith movie
and then you'd probably [__] do a
William Shatner impression
[Laughter]
I'm just kidding little Ralph
a big Ralph
you're a nicer stoned
so true
this is from Beau in Texas he said
listening to you guys since I was 24 and
this is my first email into the show it
doesn't say how old he is no yeah really
oh it does it does yeah the May 20th
show happens to coincide with my 32nd
birthday I'm not able to be there to
celebrate with you guys as I would like
to but I was wondering if Ralph could do
me a favor and do just a little part of
quint's speech from Jaws as my favorite
impression Edwin thank you so much for
what you do Bo Torres sure Bo happy
birthday just lots of [__] video on
this show just a little chunk a little
chunk of that speech work the camera
[__] all right
sometimes the shock looks right at you
right into your eyes and the thing about
a shark is it's got lifeless eyes don't
you know black eyes like a doll's eyes
but when he comes at you he doesn't even
seem to be living until he bites you and
those black eyes roll over white and
then all you hear is that terrible
high-pitched screaming
the ocean turns red and despite all your
pounding and hollering those sharks come
in and they rip you to pieces don't you
know there you go that's all he's
getting for his birthday
oh
that movie would have been so much more
watchable yes
so anyway we delivered the bomb
nice pool fun very good uh folks send us
emails all the time with different stuff
but one of my favorites is when they're
in their travels they run across a town
with a [__] up name and we again we
never bothered to really name this
segment so we just call it your Town's
got a [__] up name
[Music]
Kyle Fouts in San Dimas San Dimas
football rules
wow nice pull uh pulled this one in when
he was traveling in Pennsylvania my home
state he came across this little town
Shartlesville oh [__] yeah
right next to squirtzburg
I'm not mistaken
we also love to run across things uh or
the the uh Hollywood Babylon listeners
do they run across things that are meant
for children things are supposed to be
enjoyed by children and when you look at
them you realize these are inappropriate
toys
[Music]
first one comes from Samantha lusted she
says we all need some Jesus in our lives
right I found this for kids at a local
charity shop here in the UK this is
something for the kids I think
inflatable Jesus go inflate them play
with him pray with him
he's always there for you
unless someone's got a pin
here's your chance to blow the Lord
my favorite part of the box he floats on
water
you listen to the stories right there
uh this one's from AJ fuerman AJ are you
here tonight hi AJ how are you good uh
no one this is a staple of kids in terms
of playsets the old doctor set yeah this
is a great one can we see take a look at
this doctor set
yeah
can we can we zoom in on the doctor said
a little bit just yeah
I'm not quite sure why the shotgun your
prognosis is not good
unless you're a doctor in Texas I don't
understand why you have the gun in your
doctor's cat
what do I know Kyle Matthews sent these
in he said you know how hard it is to uh
potty train kids
do you remember it's been a few years
there's been a few it did trust me it's
hard a lot of kids they balk at the idea
initially well not anymore not when you
introduce them to some of their favorite
friends here's the first one oh [__]
right
oh my God I would totally [__] in that
you couldn't stop the kids from [__]
on spidey's lap yeah look at that man
what if your kid has to go real fast
oh [__]
what have you taken the family out for
dinner at Taco Bell
well then
I need a sturdier toy that's an
intimidating toilet right yes it is
that's how I feel usually after talking
about it
uh we've lost some people this week in
the entertainment business who gave all
of Samantha's relatives yes
that's what you get for sharing Samantha
opening up that's right uh giving us
bodies of work will enjoy for many years
to come sadly they were taken too soon
they are the Tinseltown stiffs and now
another edition of
[Music]
they will be missed I'm not a big
wrestling guy but even I knew this name
Superstar Billy Graham has passed away
at the age of 79. here's a shot of him
in his prime wow
with his belt he was an icon a
bodybuilder of course and famous
wrestler but more importantly a big time
Mentor for some of the biggest names in
the game Hulk Hogan Ric Flair Jesse
Ventura oh he took them all under his
wing and sort of learned taught them how
to be his bombastic and as large as he
was a ladies guy right
um I think 70s and 80s yeah
we also lost Jim Brown great NFL star
but also star of motion pictures as well
famously The Dirty Dozen Running Man Any
Given Sunday Tim Burton's Mars Attacks
you may remember he's the uh the
heavyweight champ who's working at the
casino there Spike Lee's he's got game
um in the running man he was one of the
villains in uh that Schwarzenegger film
here he is in his prime in the 1960s
Legend and lastly Andy Rourke bassist
for the Smiths passed away this week at
the age of 59. how old 59 years old not
that old man now a battle with
pancreatic cancer took him way too soon
um he joined the Smiths in 1982 and
played alongside the band until they're
split in 1987. one of the great bassists
in rock history here's a little bit of
the work of The Smiths
[Music]
just like everybody else
even after the split with the band Jason
Muse heard that he'd be like [__]
Charmed that's right
I was in Charmed yes you're right sir I
was
thank you for remembering
because nobody else how dare you sir
I need two episodes of charm did you
really yes what did you play I was the
DJ at the P3 which was the club that the
three sisters opened up on the show
how'd that happen
um I uh could you blow to get that I
didn't blow anybody
I got a call how dare you
I got a call from one of the producers
who was a listener of the the morning
show here in Los Angeles did that happen
a lot and I said we need to we need a DJ
and we like your voice we thought you'd
do it so come on down so I introduced
Dishwalla in one season when they came
out and The Cranberries in another
season the [__] those are two like
actual bands at the time they were white
hot did you have a character name uh yes
P3 DJ
so were they all on set did you see all
the proof I met all the girls did you
really yes and uh most of them were very
nice
do tell
a little Hollywood tea no
um Shannon was always adult too and then
we worked together years later again on
that uh
sitcoms and she was sweet the fox
shortcoms and um
um yeah that's all that's all I needed
they were the stress the girls were
stressed they had a lot on their plate
so I don't take anything are they doing
spells and [__]
yes they can't they cast a spell on me
and my balls got huge and that's why I'm
still carrying a grudge
did that happen a lot like people listen
to you on the radio and be like come
being I got a lot of gigs that way yeah
for some reason they're like oh you
claim to be an actor why don't you come
down here and do a little something on
our show you showed them that you were I
sometimes yes what else did you get to
be on I got I started working on Family
Guy because I was on the radio seriously
the casting director for Family Guy
heard me doing some Impressions they're
like oh we got a bit we're doing Dustin
Hoffman in this week's episode can you
come down and do it and I was like yeah
so I went down and I met Seth and I did
the thing and he thought it was funny
and then he started bringing me back and
now I've been on over 200 episodes of
Family Guy all right man
were you ever like um I do a mean Adam
West like we got the real good they got
the real guy yeah
but Adam and I used to hang out in the
green room while we were waiting to
record on that show because he'd come in
to do Mayor West and I'd come in to do a
bunch of voices and so we would always
like once a week we would shoot the [__]
in the green room and just hang out
together having Adam westoff and shoot
yeah that's not what I sound like Ralph
say that all the time
it should be pointed out I know we've
talked about it a zillion times but you
got the Mana star in the Walk of Fame I
I played a role in it yeah for sure yeah
and in the in return he asked me to
speak uh on the day when they put when
they gave him the survey it was just he
asked me and Seth macfarland to speak on
his behalf exactly special day I miss
him he's a good guy yeah abbased g
Magnus it's me Kevin
Jason you have you ever wanted to get
lost on the high seas with Jay and
Silent Bible now you're gonna have your
chance go to Jay and Silent Bob
cruisesque.com right now and sign up for
Jay and Silent Bob's Cruise Askew we're
gonna hit the high seas where we going
Gilligan we're gonna be going to Miami
to Nassau Bahamas and into Norwegian
Pearl doesn't that sound great it's
gonna be me and him it's gonna be all of
our friends we'll be doing live podcasts
there's going to be a movies on board
there's gonna be a viewer skew Museum
great times to be had by all ladies and
gentlemen tickets available right now go
buy them man and if you sign up before
June 23rd it's only 100 down per cabin
what are you waiting for man get lost at
sea with Jay and Silent bone let's do it
um there are things that happen in
television shows and movies that uh
you're not supposed to see but we see
him anyway so we call those [__] that
should not be
[Music]
foreign
this one comes from Carter in Chicago
Carter picked one of my favorite films
although quite what the hell
damn it
keep me safe
is that how you play with a doll you're
like
give it a little life man like [__]
hahaha
that's how people move yeah it's very
lifelike
got polio
[Laughter]
he's on his knees he's on his knees yeah
it's Hollywood baby please
uh Carter sent this in from one of my
favorite worst films of all time Samurai
cop has anyone seen Samurai cop it's
it's a special awful film I was in the
sequel Samurai cop too if you ever find
it you were in the sequel I paid to be
in the sequel
it's the only time I paid someone else
so I could act inside an auction or
something it was they were doing a uh
GoFundMe to raise money to do the film
and if you paid a certain amount of
money they'd put you in a cameo in the
film and I was like [__] yeah I'm gonna
be in this what promises to be the
second worst film of all time
I had no idea if like the next time I'm
putting you in a movie I'm gonna be like
yeah
I have to be one I want to want to be in
the movie though that's the only thing
wow
don't be sad
[Music]
it's very very limber
so many awful scenes in this film but
this one's particularly funny it says
these bullet wounds apparently you only
bleed after they cut away from the guy
who gets shot if he knows every time
this guy gets shot he grabs his chest
there's no blood in the Cutaway when
they come back that's when you see the
blood it was a it was a cheap it was a
cheap shoot
welcome
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
and also sometimes we highlight
performances that are so bad that
Exquisite acting goes all no bad acting
goes all the way around to become
Exquisite acting
that is
welcome to the world of Exquisite acting
with Ralph Garman and Kevin Smith
uh this film comes from Robert Benner in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania my hometown
um this scene is from a movie called
Second Glance which is a religious drama
from 1992 about a young Christian boy in
a public high school who feels that his
religion is restricting him from having
a good time in school so he wishes that
Jesus had not saved him and much like
it's a wonderful life he gets Jesus
taken away from his life and he has to
live with the repercussions you [__]
serious this is a real thing
and by the end I'm sure he realizes that
it's a good thing Jesus said yes without
Jesus there are no answers the Bible has
all the answers and then he inflates
that Jesus inflatable Jesus yes
and uh here's the ending of the film
where he realizes that his best friend
who's also uh his best friend in Jesus
is Alive although in the there was a in
that moment where he was not saved his
his friend died and so he's so happy to
see him and it's the greatest perhaps
last line ever in the history of a film
this is from Robert sent this in from
Philadelphia here's the ending scene of
Second Glance
man
it's all about delivery right oh yes
Jesus man he's like Jesus man Jesus man
I am going to leave every room for the
rest of my life
that's your sign off on that note Jesus
man
can we see that one more time Josh
can you replay that for me
[__] hell
oh
Jesus man Jesus man
[Music]
that's time to take a look at all the
entertainment news in a segment we call
the HBO headlines
[Music]
there's a strike going on I don't know
if you know this or not in Show Business
the [__] you said yeah wga writers have
gone on strike Jesus man
Jesus man
I saw you out there on the picket line I
did I joined uh
Mark Mark Bernardin uh our buddy has
been uh you know going out since the
strike began and uh I was like I want to
go and so he taught me how to strike
this my first
strike ever first time I ever walked a
picket line and I gotta tell you it's
[__] fun
I mean I know it's a bad making the best
of a worse situation yeah it was cool I
ran into like [__] writers that like
not every writer is like visually famous
right right like you could know
somebody's work you know the name they
look like and then another name and so
uh Drew Goddard who did the first season
of net of Netflix's Daredevil yeah right
Brian K Vaughn why the last man
at one point mark was talking these two
dudes and [__] and then uh you know he
said there and he said this is a Drew
and Brian but they didn't go any further
than that so I was letting them Chit
Chat and insinuate myself in the
conversation I I guess I was looking a
little aloof and [__] and then they went
in One Direction we went another and I
asked Marco I was like who are those
guys and he was like oh it's true
Goddard and Brian came on I was like why
did you [__] tell me man like I know
those [__] dudes so thankfully we saw
them again and I got to be like I I he
only told me later who the [__] you guys
are and Brian came on was like I thought
you hated me
um but yeah man it was kind of cool I
met a lot of like fellow writers baby
writers people who had like nice things
to say like I'm in this job because I
saw clerks and I realized if that's a
movie I could [__] write
[__] like that a lot of people going
like I saw your video are you okay man
and I was like yeah
so it was good times out there man they
give you a blank sign you can write
whatever the [__] you wrong you want I
wrote without writers Hollywood is
Silent Bob
a little self-serving a little
self-serving but you know uh sadly the
strike means a lot of other people are
out of work because some of these shows
have shut down like the late night shows
Jimmy Fallon and Colbert and uh
um Seth Meyers as well and it was sad
news this week when we found out that
the non-writing staff members of the
Jimmy Fallon show have been put on what
they're calling unpaid leave of absence
until the strike is over meaning
nobody's getting paid on those shows all
right uh Seth Meyers and Stephen Colbert
is continuing to pay their staff even
during the strike unit but the class
but the Jimmy Fallon show with its night
show not paying their uh their staff
members they told me that when I was on
the strike line they told me that um
if you know right now it's just the
writer's Guild but I guess sag is taking
a strike vote for authorizing them to
strike they did yeah and uh but I was
also told if the DGA joined the strike
the strike would end just like that they
said the last time the DJI struck this
[__] Hollywood was like all right all
right after like two [__] days or
something so [__] yeah because a lot of
scripts are already done you can still
make product but you can't do it without
a director isn't that crazy I had no
idea good thing I'm a hyphenate all
right but it's it's nuts man how little
they give a [__] about the writer like
keep [__] striking like ABC announced
their [__] schedule for the fall
already yeah and it's a gazillion
[__] so reality shows and [__] and
then reruns of uh what was it called The
Habit
what happened Costello yes bringing them
out of mothballs and [__] that's not
what I'm asking you who's the guy stick
at first
oh my God that would make me end the
strike right there
but if the DJ were to join the strike
and even sag sag's got like [__] 180
000 members and [__] yeah but you can
make a thing without writers
um you can make a thing without actors
because you could do reality right but
you can't make [__] without a director's
son words
well talk to your boys and get a strike
on balls your boys your director boys
you're the directors true okay Tarantino
on the line say what's up
I don't do I have any director friends I
guess I do
look Affleck yeah good point he's a
director sometimes sometimes
these are good at directors you see air
I've not seen air yet no did he direct
that too you did and I've went to the
premiere like months ago and [__] but
it's on Amazon Prime right now I watched
it twice in one week it's a [__]
totally good movie like honestly I think
it's his best and you know he did Argo
yeah he did but uh it's good flip
uh Sports Illustrated has announced
they're going to have the oldest model
in history on the cover of their
swimsuit edition Jesus man that model is
81 year old Martha Stewart I don't know
if you've seen the cover or not but
she's 81. she's 81. she looks great I
would wreck that
would destroy her
you'd show her turn her bones to powder
she's done time yeah she knows a trick
or two at that really maybe turn your
bones to powder
near one bone bend me over
she'd be like your turn give me that
osteoporosis [__]
this is Martha Stewart oh is it okay
we should have dolls of ourselves in
every show reminds me too much of
therapy
where did Kevin touch you Ralph
where did he hurt you right here in the
heart right in the heart
uh Indiana Jones 5 premiered at the
Cannes Film Festival this week how about
that I don't know if it was a good idea
man uh there has seen the review there
has been a middling response as they say
right now it's like under 50 I think on
Rotten Tomatoes if you give a [__] about
that sort of thing but it felt like you
know they were like let's go to can woo
and now they're like why did we go to
Camp yeah now admittedly there was like
a six minute standing ovation after the
film was over but they kind of six yeah
I believe clerks two got eight so
whatever
just say I'm just saying
um but yeah the [__] Indiana Jones
biggest villain right now are [__]
critics
Harrison Ford who's also turning 81 in a
couple months it's a good week for 81
year olds apparently truly put him on
the [__] he was
he was in tears during the standing
ovation we have a picture of him
actually feeling something which is
a rare rare moment I wonder what that
would sound like
[Music]
[Laughter]
laughs
[Applause]
so he felt no [__] man I think that
is my favorite impression you do this is
legit hysterical that you [__] he and
it sounds like him as well
I saw him on uh they did he was on Good
Morning America live from [__] can
and they were like what are you gonna
miss about playing Indiana Jones and he
was like nothing not an 81 I bet he's
like I've done it it's over nothing
um reboots remakes reimaginings of shows
hitting the airwaves again we often say
no thanks we already got one
[Music]
we've done it another one it's already
been gone
this week TBS cable channel has
announced a re-imagining of a show
called The Joe Schmo Show which was
don't boo that means Ralph gets work
yeah
not so much what happened I thought you
were the host uh for three seasons of
that show I was the uh host and one of
the characters and uh it's a it's a
brand new crew and they're going in what
they say a different direction
ralphless ralphless cat dealy will be
the new host
she was the host of uh So You Think You
Can Dance
I think it's the name of the show she
was on
um uh I think she has another show
called called so you think you can host
I'm kidding she's what's uh what was
this how how what the like about a year
ago I got a call from my agents and they
said oh interesting news They're
bringing back The Joe Schmo Show and The
Producers want to talk to and I was like
all right I'll have that conversation
Right Back Where I Belong [__] yeah
front and center on television yeah just
like it's Charmed that's right
and so they call me up they say oh yeah
we're gonna do the show again but you're
we don't need you to host so much we'd
like you to do like a cameo though to
sort of tie in the previous version to
this new reimagined version and I said
what how are you reimagining it they
said well we're getting one guy who
doesn't know what's going on and we're
gonna surround him with a bunch of
actors playing roles and he doesn't know
until the very end of the whole thing's
about him I said wow that really is
reimagining the whole Concepts you guys
are brilliant
um they said we want to do like a cameo
thing with you and I was like uh they
explained the idea and I was like oh you
know what for the fans of the original
show it might be fun for them to see me
in it so talk to my people and see what
the deal is going to be like and we'll
see
so weeks go by and we don't hear
anything and I get a call one day from a
guy who says hi okay we need to get your
covet test because you're working
tomorrow in The Joe Schmo Show and I'm
like no I'm not I don't have a deal in
place or anything and no one got back to
us with this idea of me doing a cameo
and he's like well you're on the call
sheet so we got to do it congratulations
you got a job and I was like
this is this your first week in Show
Business kids he sounded like he's 12.
and I said no I don't I don't have a
contract I don't know what the money's
like I don't know what the role is I
don't know anything and it's like oh wow
that's that's oh that's a problem I'm
like yeah he's like Jesus man Jesus man
so I said talk to your guys and then
have them call my guys and I call my
management I was like did anyone did you
hear from the Joe schmother's like no
why I said they just called me said I'm
working tomorrow I said we'll get to the
bottom of this so they called them and
then the guy the guy who wraps me is a
sweetheart of a man he called me and
said yeah I hate to be this guy but
here's what they're offering to pay you
to be on the show and I was like wow
that's insulting really yeah and I said
tell them good luck
good riddance so
Joe Schmo Show
coming back I'm sure it'll be awful I
mean lovely you're wonderful whatever
it's gonna be
and from time to time we check in with
uh Justin Bieber as well
right
because oh wow
yeah they love that cut part man
Haley Bieber says she's scared to have
kids with Justin Bieber
I don't blame her either man
means [__] Justin Bieber first of all
that's the first problem
um she says I literally cry about this
all the time
why [__]
I want kids so bad but I get scared it's
enough that people say things about my
husband but I can't imagine having to
confront people saying things about my
child so she's concerned about the
public reaction to her procreating It's
Gonna Hurt
I'm sure that's part of it yeah I've
seen a child be born it's [__] it
ain't pretty
since being married to Justin I've been
I've Heards of my life
can you imagine all the tracks
all those times on yachts and just
jetting around and just living in
palatial homes and stuff it sounds
awesome yeah but then you gotta look
over and see you're married to and
you're like oh [__] yeah that's true
Jesus man Jesus man
we got some geek news for you as well
big news
um flash [__] Michael Keaton returning
as Batman in the new Flash
it's giving me [__] life has sparked
new interest in the original films
Batman and Batman Returns of course that
he starred in so much so that Lego is
introducing the new Batman Returns Lego
Batcave set have you seen this thing
yeah I have just threw up a picture real
quick he's a big Lego kid so he was 4
000 different pieces to create this
Batman Returns Batcave set well oh look
at the Vault the Vault where you know
with the with the costumes and the
Batmobile and everything uh it is coming
out on June 5th it can be yours for the
low low price of 450 dollars
something every kid can afford
absolutely
um think about it man we're gonna like
there's only been two Michael Keaton
Batman movies I know I've seen all of
The Adventures of Michael Keaton as
Batman now we're about to see a [__]
third it's almost like getting a third
Batman movie with Michael Key I think
that's why everyone's excited it's crazy
so many years later and [__] like that
he looks great too everything and that
[__] a trailer he's like let's get nuts
I was like
I wonder if they're gonna repeat like
every line he ever said
so happy all 69 with a man yeah
I hope he repeats every [__] line
so flash you ever Dance with the Devil
in the pale moonlight
just like everyone one after another is
just there do I hope he ref you know I'm
so excited I hope he references
everything I hope he talks about like
one time I fought the Joker and one time
I fought Max Shrek and then that's it
they should bring back Shrek back for
this one it's a Multiverse right yeah
have him come back
so ah I was wondering where you're going
with this Flash
you're very fast
you go Zoom
you're there one minute gone the next
pay to see that now do your Michelle
Pfeiffer yeah
it's [__] adorable thank you it's
right up there with your Harrison Ford
thank you
and uh Disney has announced they're
permanently shuttering its expensive
interactive Star Wars Star Wars Hotel
the galactic Star cruise already yeah
they only opened it last year it's a
year old and they said yeah this may
have not been the best idea
they're closing it shutting it down the
last Voyage will be September 28th so if
you want to ride on the galactic Star
cruise or your last chances to get in
before September 28th I mean that was a
major investment uh they're saying well
depending on what you ask if 90 million
dollars to build up the immersive
experience to go on this hotel and it's
supposed to be like you're traveling
through space on a star Cruiser no
windows only TV screens that look like
space and everyone the entire staff are
performers and they make you believe
that you're immersed in the world of
Star Wars wow
um it was the low low price I think that
uh kept people away the twelve hundred
dollars per person per day and that they
lowered it originally it was like six
thousand for three days yes that was the
first price I think that might have been
a problem with the uh with the
the Excursion the appealing to the one
percent of the one percent I think also
the problem is when you checked into
your hotel this was a typical room
so for for twelve hundred dollars I
don't want to be staying in a Swedish
youth hostel
[Laughter]
I would like a little luxury I think on
the galactic star Cruiser truly man it's
not gonna be sleeping under a crack
dealer or something from Norway what do
they do with all that space man I don't
know
oh
any ideas
Jesus man
The View ask Universe yeah your own
theme park let me tell you if Star Wars
can't make it work I don't think Jade's
album could make it work either but we'd
be a lot [__] cheaper than six
thousand bucks that's true 60 bucks a
night
your house yes
all right we're almost done here kids
but before we say good night really yeah
it
oh [__] hey man
before we say good night we're gonna
marry these two kids one more time no no
no before we say goodnight we have the
last bit of business we always like to
uh listen to you guys talk about the
size of Liam Neeson's [__] one of our
favorite
indeed
[Music]
you'd like to contribute your own facts
about leaving Mrs [__] you can always
write us at HBO podcast aol.com you can
send us anything for any of the segments
at that email address yes I still use
AOL
these folks sent in these facts about
Liam's [__] this week Liam Neeson's [__]
is so big
so big it's going to replace Tucker
Carlson on Fox News
I didn't know it was that big of a dick
but
Liam Neeson's [__] is so big
he actually
Brazilian soccer team to their games
we've got some video of that happen
here's him dropping them off at the game
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a pretty tight [__] action there
man
how relieving it must be after they're
all out right
Liam Neeson [__] is so big
it's co-starring with Emma Stone in her
new film we've got a shot from the set
his cock's playing a picture window I
believe in the set right behind Emma
it's pointing down he's not ready he's
not ready at all
five minutes Mr [__]
Liam needs his [__] is so big
it made an appearance at King Charles
coronation not if you saw that or not no
here it is outside the groundhog
someone actually mowed that into the
lawn outside are you [__] me no it
actually absolutely happened yeah which
I love
cheeky Brits you're gonna be king and
he'll look at and you're like they don't
like me yeah
and lastly Liam Neeson's [__] is so big
the wga is using it to block the
entrances of all the major Studios
ladies and gentlemen of Burbank if you
had a good time this evening
thank you so much for spending some time
with us we truly appreciate it there
would be no show my friends were it not
for the [__] comedic talents of the
man to my left give it up for the great
Ralph Garmin everybody
let's do it for my bestest buddy and
Babel brother Mr Kevin Smith
and that is Hollywood Babylon for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Carmen
[Applause]
give it up for Ralph Garmin and Kevin
Smith
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
foreign